I think you're going to be proud of me
for what I'm about to tell you I was
really really close to coming to you
today with a positive story from the
Trump administration something good that
Donald Trump had done that I could tell
you about the story was going to be how
great it was that Donald Trump signed a
NASA funding bill and he's added human
exploration of Mars to NASA's mission
because that's how the story has been
reported by some media outlets how great
unfortunately it is not actually the
positive story I planned to come to you
with the new law does authorize nineteen
point five billion in spending for NASA
but as Elon Musk has astutely pointed
out on Twitter this basically does
nothing it just reauthorizes existing
programs Elon Musk tweeting recently I
this bill changes almost nothing about
what NASA is doing existing program stay
in place and there is no added funding
for Mars Elon Musk is completely correct
not only is Elon Musk correct though
this is an authorization it doesn't
actually provide the funding that comes
from appropriations committees and
secondly despite reports what Trump
signed does nothing to add to Mars
funding much of the general news
coverage after Trump signed this focused
on oh the legislation calls for sending
humans to Mars like for example The
Associated Press headlined it's story
Trump signs bill authorizing NASA
funding comma Mars exploration according
to sources at ARS technica rather
according to sources that ARS technica
has spoken to this would be something
that actually has does not have any
interest within the trump administration
more than likely this entire thing along
with the signing session that you can
see in this picture here and the jokes
and the pandering it was all to distract
from the areas of science that actually
are having their funding cut in Trump's
proposed budget this includes the
National Institutes of Health and so
much
else and while the White House has
directed NASA to no longer study earth
climate issues you could actually make a
pretty strong case that trumps
relationship with NASA is a disastrous
one not the one made to appear to be
really great by this picture with all
these people who are smiling is it
possible though that Elon Musk is trying
to downplay this signing because he
operates SpaceX which is in ways is a
competitor to NASA so maybe he has his
own financial interests and trying to
make this seem like no big deal
brilliant question wrong no I mean it's
a good point but SpaceX is working with
the US government on a lot of these
contracts and and increasingly because
of changes that have been made to the
NASA space program SpaceX and I believe
also boeing have gotten some contracts
to do some of the work that NASA would
have been presumed to have done so like
a public-private partnership exactly so
conceptually what you're saying your
skepticism is absolutely warranted it
doesn't actually appear to be the case
and in this particular incident but I
like the skepticism that I like it but
the real red alert here is NASA has been
directed by the White House to no longer
study Earth's climate issues which is a
big effing deal and that's actually
that's the big NASA story from my point
of view under the trump administration
that there now no longer allowed to
study or climate issues with which of
course relates to the trump position on
climate change and destroying our
environment with fossil fuels well if
you were looking for a silver lining in
this story we need Cruz and Marco Rubio
were in that room when Trump authorized
that built yeah and they had so suck up
to the president completely you know
that was great to watch I think there's
a bigger silver lining by being in the
room with Trump while he was signing
this they weren't elsewhere doing more
damage maybe maybe that's a silver
lining that we can find from this entire
NASA charade today's episode of the
david pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker I glasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five day home try-on from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not where
contact lenses I started with the free
at home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which one do you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription
into I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like an
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses with Warby Parker
they started just 95 bucks mine cost
that including lenses and for every pair
sold they give a pair to someone in need
so to try the five pairs and support the
david pakman show go to Warby Parker
trial com /t DPS